Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to 60 seconds!
This time! We're gonna win!
I know what I need to do!
Ok. So I actually have not been using my scouting time properly.
I need to, one: scout the area.
There's the radio, right there. tha- Oh, this is perfect, this is exactly what I need, right off the bat!
Because I need, I'm salivating at the thought of the success that I'm about to have!
Get it! I know, I know, I know. That, that, that and no room for that. Shit!
Get this, just get it!
Just go, go go!
Okay, so what I've been doing wrong is I've been getting too much of the stuff that I don't need-
This is a different distribution than I had before.
Why is this over here? Why is this over here?
I don't know why any of this is in the place that it is!
This doesn't make any goddamn sense-
But it's okay. It's okay. It's okay. It's okay. Okay.
Get it, get it, get it, get it. Gotta get my family members eventually, but I need to get the soup first
Okay, so the main problem that I've been having
is that I've been getting the wrong things right off the bat!
Nabadibadibadiba [Markiplier talks alien]
Okay, gotta get the rest of my family, gotta get this can of soup
Gotta get that gas mask
ahh I don't need the gas mask because I don't need to send anyone out before it's time to go out
But I'm gonna get it anyway
WHERES MY WIFE??
Ohh god Where's my wife? Where's my wife? Where's my wife?
Where's my goddamn wiiIIFE?
Come over here wife!
WIFE
Get that
Get it
Get- no ROOM?? What the frick
AAAHH [panics]
TITTIES [panics]
AHHH [squeals]
IN! IN! IN! IN! IN!
Okay,
so,
that could have gone infinitely better.
That was not good at ALL!
We didn't do ANYTHING that we needed to do!
But we started off with the right things.
We may be low on food,
but with the Boy Scout Manual-
-I've been told this-
You can survive
Five
Five days in between food
And it looks like we actually had more food down here than we needed before
I didn't get the map.
It's one of the things I desperately needed was the map
And we found a can of soup down here
And also we found nothing else.
So.
So every five days
Every FIVE days
We can feed and water our people
Because now that we have the Boy Scout Manual,
That leaves us some more leeway for what we need to do
AND we have the deck of cards
which means that we have something to keep us occupied
Okay.
Everyone's fine
Everyone's gonna be fine
We need to-
We DON'T need an expedition
Oh
What's that trickling sound? And why is the wall so wet?
Are we about to get flooded?
We don't have life preservers
Save the supplies - yup
Save the radio! Gotta get the radio
This is already off to a bad start
I can tell that things are just about going to be bad for ME IN THIS ENVIRONMENT!
Either this is going to be the worlds shortest game that was ever played
or this is-
[laughing]
Oh man.
Okay! Everyones still alive. Good.
Every five days
It's every five days
Got it
Okay so every five days everybody gets one of everything
That's gonna make our rations last a LONG time
This is insane! We keep finding spiders everywhere
They're in our soup. They're in our water.
We swear some of them keep coming back
and they are bigger every time we see them
it can't go on like this it's time to wage war on the spiders
This better not loose me the Boy Scout Manual
Because if it does
I'm going to send EVERY ONE of my family members
INTO the radioactive waste,
AND HAVE THEM DIE
FROM DEATH POISONING
It better have turned out good for me
ok
Good book is a solution to any problem to any encounter
got to battle on with plus one soup can
everything works out for the best
If there is anyone out there that can rescue us
It's the government
Since the government worked out so well for us last time
I say this family is on their own and if you don't listen to me
then you're probably very sane
'Cause I'm crazy!
LISTEN TO ME I'm the dad here
I think
Anyway
Hearing strange noises lately
Is that coming from outside or is that something in the shelter with us? Could it be?
We found nothing. We feel like we're going crazy
We should probably get busy with
something to keep us occupied.
I WOULD have cards
but I'm playing on the game mode that causes problems
if one of us breaks our radio in our bor-
Oh God everyone has gone insane [at his very moment markiplier knew he fucked up]
Wow.
That was fast
Holy shit.
I didn't know that was possible
I'm se-
[coughing]
Ha ha. We could live with them noises, right?
We can even be friends. Ha ha.
So it's not weird that Timmy  is now wearing a soup can on his head and pretends its a helmet?
This is just innocent child's play. Or is it?
Mary Jane started acting even more crazy than she usually does
And she seems to be making a nest
Was it the soup?
Boredom can really get to you in the shelter
It can lead you into dark places. Trust us.
Ohh man
EVERYONE has gone CRAZY
Ohh God
Dolores - leave this hellish hole!
Dolores go!
Ohh my god everyone's gone NUTS
Ohhh everyone's gonna wander into the Wasteland!
This is going to be the shortest game I've ever played in this.
Dolores: You get out there
You be good
And you bring back something or else we are all dead
And that is guaranteed
Go Dolores!
Leave your insane family alone in this hellhole!
So Dolores is out
and while Dolores is out
Everythings gonna be-
Everything's gonna be FINE
Everything'sth gonna be fine in the hellhole of insthanithy!
The bunker of noisesth in our headsth!
When we opened the bunker door this morning to let in some fresh radioactive air
We discovered a small suitcase on our doorstep
There was no note on it and the neighborhood seemed empty.
Should we take a look inside?
Of course!
Why WOULDN'T we trust that?
We'd be crazy not to
[maniacal laughter]
Ohh
Okay
Timmy doesn't look so good
Inside the suitcase we found some soup but yuck!
It expired a long time ago
We're not feeling very well, some of us spent the whole morning using the bucket in the corner.
We're not accepting anonymous gifts ever again
Well.
Tits.
This is going BAD
This is going about the worst I've ever done something.
We were suspicious and cautious but after a few minutes of talking
it turned out it was just a group of old ladies
Oh yeah! These are the old ladies that are very bad.
And that wanted to rob us
BUT I STRIKE FIRST
I PROTECT MY OWN
YOU STOP TRYIN TO BEAT DOWN MEE
Ohh my gun exploded
What happens if the rifle malfunctions or we use all our ammo?
Huh?
What did the-
Why'd the gun-
Why'd the gun break??
Oh god
This is going badly.
I'm just gonna rush to the end of this one because we're not gonna suvive here.
This is obviously not gonna go well.
OH DOLORES you're back!
You don't look so good
You found very little.
In fact you only found water.
Okay whatever we're dead here.
Just dead.
[laughing]
Timmy really outdid himself today
In a frenzy he tore out all the
pages from his beloved Scout Handbook
and just transformed them into dozens of paper planes.
They were flying all over the place
And although we tried to catch as many as we could,
that really wasn't many,
most of them landed in soups stains and in the bucket
Unfortunately the pages we managed to rescue aren't of much use to us:
The table consisting of contents
and the chapter listing a hundred ways to properly take care of a Scout uniform
greeaat
Everyone's dead
Everyones going to die this very night
Radio of ours is silent. We need news
Meddle with it.
YEAH break the radio. Good idea.
Leave it to CRAZY TED to break the-
Yep. Okay.
Welp they're dead!
And Dolores is just left there with her friggin skeleton
That is great
Everyone's dead. Everyone's dead Everyone's dead. Everyone's dead. Everyone's dead. Everyone's dead.
Everyone's gonna die die die die DIE DIE DIE DIE DIE
The eeend!!
We all st-
Oh my god Dolores
okay
Obviously
That is not the end of this episode
I thought it was going to go better than this
But that's not the way that we're going to have it
We're gonna start a new game
This is a recipe in failure
That was the example of how NOT to succeed in the game
And this next one is going to be much better
It's gonna be good because I'm going to find everything that I need right off the bat
[singing] This time we're going to win GOOD!!
Like we should've in the first place yeah!
Let's survive the apocalypse NOW
It's not quite like Fallout the game!
But when we have our family DOWN
We're gonna love each other forever
Not go insane again yeah!
Let's!
[normal] Start the goddamn thing
Ready freddy ready freddy reADY FREDDY
GET YOU! Myswell! You're big!
Okay
Here we go. Here we go.
Got that
Oh, Timmy, what a perfect place for you to be!
I'm just gonna dump you right in!
Okay that looks like the boyscout handbook!
I don't know where the map is!!!
I don't know where that is!!!!
Ohh god oh god oh god.
That
Nice cards need that
Euhhhhdededuhdeduhduhdeduhduhdeuduhduhduh
Where's the fricken-
THERE'S THE MAP
IT'S ON THE WALL
nyuUERRderr.
herner
hurdeh
okay
ohh man
ohh man oh man oh man
There's a lot of soup in one spot here
hurep
Any of these?
Okay no room?
That's fine that's fine that's fine
Dump those in there
Okay get the... fireaxe
Thaat
To the shelter
We can get one more one more one more
One more
Get that
BRIEFCASE BRIEFCASE BRIEFCASE
GET THAT GET THAT GET THAT GETTIT
AHHH GEDDIT GEDDIT GEDDIT
EUURRRRRRRRNNNN
YES
YES YES YES YES YES YES YES
I hope I didn't forget anyone
Did I forget any of my important important family members?
Noo??
Good.
Okay we got a lot of material in this one
We got a LOT of material
Everything was laid out pretty much perfectly for us to get exactly what we need
because we have the map, radio, flashlight, handbook!
We have the axe. We have a suitcase!
We have a gun, ammo, soup!
We do NOT have a lot of water...
But we have both the cards, checkerboard AND medkit
AND lock and key
This is about the best we could possibly get
We never thought we'd live to see a dancing cockroach
We still haven't but we saw one that was nearly as big as a cat
The good news is that they probably scared off any rats in the area
The bad news is they're huge and they'll probably attack us when they get the chance
Okay
Do not ruin the boy scout handbook!
PLEASE
Okay good it's still there
Good good good good good good GOOD
We dodged a bullet this time
That is, if a bullet was huge, hairy, had eight legs and a glowing head.
Hopefully we won't have to deal with them again
Ok.
Good good good good good good good
Okay: day five, it's feeding time, family!
We only got enough water for another one of these
We gotta find more water somehow
or we're going to be TOAST
I mean soup has some water in it!
Kinda...?
We heard somthing about supply drops on the radio
This might be just what we need to survive
and it's supposed to happen right near our house
GOD damn it
It's the only thing I don't have
The ONLY thing I do not have is a goddamn gas mask
Fricken
Sack of shit!
It-It planned that!!!
It planned that!
The commies planned that when they BOMBED us
They KNEW I wouldn't have that!
Nyer!
It's been awhile since we showered
The smell in this tiny shelter is - oh!
This is where I shower with bullets for some reason
Don't know how
Don't know how that works
But I'm gonna rub gunpowder on me and we're gonna smell real good
Maybe...
Dirty or not, it's the smell that's the biggest issue here
How do we deal with that?
Mm-yeah. Alright. Okay.
Y'know what? Okay
It's okay
Alright
Our patience is wearing thin
We thought it would be a good idea to take a quick look outside
To see if there was any trouble in the area
As we're about to sp-a pair of animal eyes!
And their owner started growling
And this is where the flashlight comes in
Because it's a puppy!
It's a little puppy pooper
He's a pupper schnupper
It is a pupper schnupper
Listen to the little puppy schnuppy
Okay
Decided to check what's coming for us with our flashlight
And it's a poor puppy
Okay
So this is where everyone gets a drink
This is the last one we got,
so we gotta start preparing for an expedition
Oh!
We didn't expect to get a phone call so soon after the atomic bomb drop,
Heard the phone ringing outside.
Someone should go answer it.
TED!
You're up, buddy
Get out there teddyboy!
You gotta show this family who's the head of the family
And you better not be sick-
Good.
No need for none of that
But we still got no water
When we answered the call we could clearly hear a gasp
...Town of Hill Valley. Okay,
I think that's the twins?
So them calling us is a good thing because
I think there's probably an ending where we can do that
Favorite radio station stopped broadcasting.
We tried other frequencies,
Maybe we should tinker with the radio to increase its range?
NO!
I'm not gonna tinker with the goddamn radio!
Frick that!
Uugh, that's my radio!
I'm not going to do anything about that!
We need that radio!
I forgot that with the briefcase
You can take a whole bunch of supplies to meet... Pretty much any scenario.
So he's gonna take...
...How long will he be gone?
It's a bit of a risk
I mean I don't even know if it's a good idea to do this
But I have a funny feeling
That he's gonna be more successful in bringing things back...
If he has these materials
So I'm gonna take a risk!
And we're gonna give them to him
He's probably going to lose one of them
And it better not be the map
He can loose everything else
Not the map
Don't lose the map
Oh crap we're gonna die...
We don't have any water
Shit shit shit shit shit.
Shit shit shit, shit.
Hey!
Because the flashlights went out I would've lost them anyway
So at least I grabbed what I needed to grab
Shit.
...We're going to die.
We don't have any water
Shit! There's no water here
We're dead. Oh. God
It's bad.
We don't have any water.
How did this happen?
We're going to die real dead.
It's real bad
Aw shit
We had such a good start
We are going to die!
Ooh no.
Guuuh.
How did Ted die...?
Okay you know what?
I'm not sending Ted out anymore
And NOO! This episode is NOT over
In fact...
Uh...
MEN IN BLACK FLASH! [Ingame: Robotic Noise]
Hello everybody! Welcome back to... Uh 60 seconds!
This is the beginning of the episode!
And we're going to do good this time.
I hope we're going to survive real good!
So here's the rub:
I...
Want to beat this game.
But I'm a little baby
I'm a little baby who's new to the world
And I need to progress
And I'm going to progress
Because I am going t-
Why is everything falling over already?
That's a little bit disconcerting for the state of everything that we're going for here
But anyway, okay
So i lowered the difficulty because-
What is-
Why is the radio screaming at me to get a medkit?
Is that- Is that a hint for what we need?
Probably
Here we go
Wh-G-What? That wasn't the radio?
What the hell???
What the hell
why was that not- not the radio?
Why was that not the radio?
It was quite obviously the radio
What the hell
It's a bunch of bullshit, that's what this is.
Okay, got those.
Take that off the wall, might as well.
Lovely wife of mine
For some reason I can't grab the radio
Oops.
Uh oh, oh god!
ohh god
[Laughter]
ohh noo!!
OH NOO!
Oh god!
[Laughter]
Oh noooo!
It threw 'em down there
[Laughing]
They're still alive down there
I threw my whole family down the hole!
Ohhh man they're alive!
Wow.
I didn't- heh...
Wh- Oh...
And they're dead. Okay!
Nevermind.
Without Ted they couldn't survive.
Because how could they, without their beloved father leading them to victory
They couldn't win
Oh man. I set the difficulty lower and I still failed.
I'm gonna do this
I may be doing it on easy
But I'm gonna do this
We're going to win and I'm going to survive
And this is where it all comes down:
To a father, understanding the limitations of what he can do
And doing what is necessary to keep his family alive
Map. Handbook. Got it
Flashlight. Tuba
[Sped Up Music]
Ok ok ok ok ok!
I think we got enough!
I think we got enough.
I think we got a lot of materials!
I think we got a lot of materials
We did good!
We're okay. Let's see what we got
I think we got everything we needed!
ohoho
huhhuhhuhhuh
That's a lot of stuff! That's a lot of stuff!
I like a lot of stuff!
All of us made it into the shelter just seconds before the blast.
That was a close one!
As long as we're all together we can make it work down here
We got a gun, bullets AND extra water
We got a gun, bullets and extra water!
Yes!
AND cards, medkit in the suitcase!
THANK YOU EASY MODE
[forced laughter]
Okay
So
We're low on food but we got enough food to survive five days
Fifteen- Fifteen days!
Which means that we can send people out with reckless abandon.
We just got more food from the lovely people banging coconuts outside!
YES!
Wait- We have three...
Wait what happened to our food, we had more food than that!
Wait- What happened to our food?
We had more food than that!
What happened?!
We were discussing plans for our first meal that didn't feature tomato soup when we heard a yell outside
We discovered it came from a small group of ragged survivors
They were a sorry sight,
And we weren't surprised when they requested aid.
We have plenty of water!
We can spare water
We can spare you water!
But nothing else... Don't even try to steal anything from us.
Ok- Our visitors had problems finding enough words to express their gratitude.
Many tears were shed - Aww.
How heartwarming
WE NEED TO SURVIVE
Alright... So we're going to send...
Dolores outside...
With the...
Suitcase.
I really... really don't know if the suitcase has any use.
Shit, she needed the gas mask
GOD DAMMIT I-
.. AUGHHHHHHH
We're not alone there's a huge hairy bunny beast that seems to be hiding in one of the pipes.
It's been poking it's head out eyeing our measly food stash. We can't let it get out
WE CAN'T LET IT BE IN HERE WHEN WE SLEEP
Ahh....
Chop its head off?
Gun it down
I... I'm gonna prefer to gun it
Shooting a gun in a confined space is always a good idea
Especially a random bun- yep
The gun blew up.
The cans were saved! Too bad for the hairy mutant. Guess we're still at the top of the food chain. Good for us.
Damn, our gun blew up when we tried to shoot the thing
Of course it did!
And I bet the axe would've blown into pieces!
It would've caught on fire sporastically
Just magically would've blown to pieces
and Dolores better come back alive or else I'm going to be very upset.
Hey! Oh-op. Dol-Dolores!
Ohhh, you look good.
hahahahahaha
You brought two food back! Which is exactly what we needed
Good good good good good
And we got a med-kit for you so you're gonna be a-okay
No worries about a goddamn thing
[forced laughter]
And just to keep everything... in sync
We thought that phone calls- OH TIMMY! RUN!
RUN TIMMY RUN!
Run Timmy! Get it
Timmy? Okay.
Dolores is looking better, she's just looking a little bit tired.
All that radiation just melted away
Just to keep everything in sync I'm gonna feed everyone
On the fifteenth, tomorrow
So everyone is gonna get fed tomorrow
Just so things can stay in sync
'cause I don't wanna worry about other people being fed-
at one point and then other people not-
I'm just gonna get everyone fed, tomorrow
doink doink doink doink
ding!
Okay, who's gonna go outside?
Ehhhr, yeah okay.
You're gonna get the suitcase 'cause I don't trust you with anything else
Oh shit
Sleeping problems, we used up our med-kit- goddamn it.
Oh no, someone's gonna go CRAZY
No? Okay! No one's crazy
Just everyone's gonna be tired
Okay
Time for eating! I don't know where Mary Jane is
she's been out a while...
Oh! Mary Jane is back and Mary Jane looks in terrible shape
but she found a lot of food!
And that is what I like- FOUR cans of food!
Might as well pack for another expedition
Timmy got back to the shelter from his expedtion and looked fine
but it turned out he had hurt his hand on a piece of rusty metal and the wound was INFECTED
doesn't look like it's healing up- we have to PATCH IT?
WITH AN AXE!?
I HAVE TO CUT HIS HAND OFF!? NO TIMMY! NOOO!
Oh.
Oh, I guess it's fine.
He looks.. okay.
Timmy was very brave about the idea of cleaning up his wound with a heated axe blade
It was a bit painful, but it was soon over
The axe is in no shape to be used again, but Timmy seems much better!
Oh! I thought we were gonna cut something OFF
We should go outside, how about little Tim-Tim?
He did okay last time, why not this time?
What could he bring?
[weird accent] Could he bring ze flashlighte?
Maybe nozing would be good for him, I cannot really risk anyzing.
Yeah, I'm gonna give him nothing 'cause I don't want him to loose nothing.
Actually, maybe we shouldn't send anyone out on an expedition, we don't exactly really NEED anything at the moment?
And
I want to make sure they get food before they go out
Because that might affect their survival chances. I dont know?
Ughh, Dolor-Ughh, Mary Jane, come on!
Mary Jane is starving... caught something nasty...
Goddammit, Mary Jane, why do you do that to yourself?
Oh shit, everyone looks bad.
I-I guess Mary Jane...
did miss out...
But I'm just going to feed everyone today
And then cycle back on the 29th
"A young woman dressed in whit knocked on our door today, telling us a story of her missing twin brother,
- who is most likely held captive."  She knows that we're good and trustworthy people and believes we can rescue her sibling, it might be the beginning of a solid friendship.
Okay! Timmy, we're gonna trust you with this one.
Gooou
Oh, you're back. You're still alive. Good.
Let's see.
The woman quickly called a group of friends and we set out for what turned out to be a successful mission.
Finding the lost twin brother wasn't a problem, he was hanging on top of some antenna trying to escape
In the duel with the Bandit leader he lost a hand, but the group quickly tended to his injuries... thanked us a hundred times...
Okay thats good
Timmy's going outsiiiiide
Timmy's taking nothing 'cause I don't trust Timmmyyyy!
Group of doctors knocked on our door today requesting some supplies that would be helpful....
We do have extra water
They offer a medkit which would be UNBELIEVABLY helpful if they did that! Please
No?
They didn't give us anything in return.
Wonderful.
Great.
Glad about that that is cool.
Every new smell attacks our noses, there isn't much else we can miss.
So when a single block fell from the wall it revealed a tight opening our senses were immediately invaded by....
We should probably check that hole out and see what the smell is
Yeah!
Best not to ignore weird smells in the walls!
And it was soup that I could spare not water
We're fuuuuudged
We approached the hole cautiously 'n what happened next gave us a heart attack some crazed rodent...
pushed our radio...
I'M ON EASY
I'M PLAYING ON EASY
I'M PLAYING ON FRIGGIN EASY
WHAT MORE DO YOU WANT FROM ME
Ohh there's timmy
[deep sigh]
Mary Jane loves cards...back from the wasteland..
Got three bottles of water!
Good!
We brought some strange looking people back to our doorstep. They claimed to be wizards and were willing to trade useful supplies for a few...
weird trinkets. After hearing them out, we decided to look around our shelter for the items they wanted
They were really ecstatic about purchasing an old pair of socks, which had been lying in the corner for some time, livin' their own life
The wizards got them in exchange for a few bottles of water, one of them placed the socks on her ears, and started to dance
They really wanted to SELL US A RADIO!!!!!!!
YEAAAHHH
I LIKE THIS! THIS IS COOL! ALRIGHT
This is good
This is good. This is good. This Is Good. This is good. This is GOOOD
So I fed them on the 33rd so that means the 38th is the next time we send some people out
Dolores you're going out with nothing again because I don't trust
The Army broadcast interrupted with our breakfast
Geographical coordinates... sign we're still alive - okay!
This is good! We got coordinates 'cause we got a map!
We got it!
Wa-wa-wkawoijasdj
Wegotit
okay
A  quick glance at the map gave us all the information we needed We also managed to send a message in a bottle.
This is good, this is good.
Why is Timmy sick? God dammit, why does everyone get sick?
How do they expect us to be able to keep people alive??
"The wasteland is full of surprises, like this man on the other side of our door,
knocking and claiming that he is willing to offer a lot for decent ammunition.
Shall we trade?"
Sure!
Why not? What else do we have to lose?
If he didn't give us a medkit, I will..
do things I never thought I do..
OOOOOOKKKKKAAAAAAAAAY.
WELL.
That is not as good as I hoped it would be.
And apparently Mary Jane is gone.
What happened to Mary Jane?
Did she run away?
"Mary Jane's sickness got worse, and when we weren't able to provide her with medicine,
she decided it's time to cure whatever she had on her own..."
Okay! That's another mouth that we don't have to feed!
So long as I make it out alive because the armory is right around the corner..
"Friendly soul on the radio was talking about a supply pack she's lost.."
We get 2 water, 1 soup, and 1 amro.
Yay.
That is good.
Boy scout handbook. Yeaaaahh.
Wait, we can try fixing the gun?
YAY!
[gasp]
Did we fit the--
OOOOHHHHHH WE DID!
TIMMY WE DID IT! YOU MIGHT BE GOING OUT OF YOUR GODDAMN MIND
BUT WE DID IT!
YEAAAAAHHHHH
Okay.
And then the 43rd is when we get to eat and drink.
Yeah! Hopelly Deloreth cometh back.
My wife, I think Iove her thtill?
Not sure at this point.
We're a month in a hole.
That'll do something to ya.
Oh no! "We don't think Dolores is coming back from the surface, it's been too long."
Shit!
Well.
That's not good.
"We almost forgot about this one time we shared some water with a group of people dressed in lab coats.
Out of the blue, they came back today and administered us some very healthy looking shots!
So they WERE real doctors after all..we think?
OH!
They gave us shots!
Did it cure timmy?!
Yeah! Timmy's just crazy now!
He's not..
He's not..he's not sick!
Uh, let's just have some celebratory food!
I mean, it's just you and me, tim-tim, for the rest of life!
Forever.
This better pay out,
because god dammit, I haven't come this far to die!
I came this far to survive!
Oh boy! "Lady luck smiled on us!We won a vicious game of war.
The man wasn't too happy about it, but he delivered on his promise."
Okay!
"Before the world turned into an unforgiving, dead wasteland,
we were friends with almost everybody in our town.
Including, the old man Jim, who would shamble through our street often and always said hello.
We wanted to visit him once, he gave us an address that took us...Old man Jim is such a joker!
It appears that he survived the blast, since he's at our door right now, asking if we want to buy a rock.
Sure! I'll buy a rock!
Hopefully this doesn't cost me the life of my only son!
[laughs]
Wouldn't that be something.
"We opened the door and greeted the old man with a smile.
He was eager to show us his bag filled with a rich choice of rocks
and convinced us to take one for free 'for old times' sake.'
We agreed...can't complain, it's a good rock...
claimed it brings us luck, we'll see about that."
Okay.
Alright Timmy, you go out. You may be crazy, but I'm not sending myself.
If anyone's gonna die, it's gonna be you and not me.
Oh Timmy, you're back.
You look slightly tired, but..at least you're still as crazy.
"Our supplies are scarce and our morale is low.
You can almost smell the desperation in the shelter.
We're pretty sure there's a small group of survivors nearby,
mostly old folks from the retirement home.
It shouldn't be hard to borrow some of their supplies. They're old and.."
No, I'm not gonna steal!
We got enough supplies, we're fiiine.
We don't need to STEAL.
Oh Timmy, he was always a wild one.
A shelter is not the best environment for a boy who's hell bent on running around until he can barely breathe.
He really misses that. He asked if he can go out to the surface, even for a short while.
This sounds highly dangerous and irresponsible. Should we agree?
Yeah!
Get out, Timmy!
GET OUT!
You freaking terror!
Stay out!
"Timmy can sneak like a secret-agent man,
but that might not be enough to avoid the band of Raiders camped near our shelter.
We can probably assume he isn't coming back.
When we consented, Timmy almost hit his head on the ceiling."
Probably cause he's crazy.
"We figured that if he doesn't encounter any savages, mutated beasts or killer mimes,
he should be fine and back enough soon."
Yeah!
He's got the survival instincts of a crazy person!
"..heard a knock on the door this morning, we held our breath in fear,
but we soon heard children's voices coming from outside.
turned out the voices belonged to a pair of girls scouts."
They offer a boy scout for a map.
I've used the map!
I've used the map. I've used the map in both contexts that I needed the map.
Which was for the radio of the government, and for the twins.
I need that book.
And Ted is a-okay.
To stay in here
for as long as he needs to!
He's got no family left,
but he was never a family man..
oh, he's gone crazy.
"The other day we heard a quiet knock on our door,
but when we opened it, it was only a suitcase and no one around,
signaled look...[mumbles]" Okay, sure.
It could kill us, but whatever.
I--I'ma trusting kinda guy.
Yup, it was sick.
Yup, bad soup.
Good good good great great great. Bad soup.
Uuuhh..
"We're about to sleep when we heard scratching from the door.
At first, it sounded like an angry rat..much worse..
something is on the other side, we need to act!"
Lock the damn door!
At least the lock is gonna be useful. Gosh.
"We didn't think a small padlock would be enough to stop them, but it turned out to be enough to discourage the unknown attackers.
It seems that they gave this whole break-in a fair shot,
but ultimately gave up and left.
Too bad that padlock is in no shape."
GREEEEEAAAAAAAT.
TIME TO EAT,
CRAZY SICK PERSON, YOU.
"afraid the army wouldn't get back to us, but they eventually did.
The next transmission was full of evacuation promises, but it ended as a big 'if'.
The speaker requested that any survivor groups armed with firearms should dispose of them before they get rescued.
We don't know what this is about, but it sounds like violating our rights.
On the other hand, are there any laws left.."
No!
I'm not giving up my gun!
You, screw you!
That didn't go out well for me last time!
Eat a dick, gov'ment!
"We decided to ignore these stupid orders.
Who are they to tell us what to do?
The US government?
Well, they probably are, but that doesn't mean they can take our gun. Over our dead bodies!
Welp.
Ted's goin' down.
Ted ain't doin good.
"bandit camp nearby..not only are they armed, dangerous, cruel and bloodthirsty.."
Fine!
Go get 'em!
Teddy boy!
Bang!
Boom bang!
Boom bang bang!
"tried out best, but they had numbers.
We didn't even manage to reach the supplies, the camp was too well-guarded. The.."
[sigh]
Yeah, go get 'em.
Go get 'em, teddy boy.
Go get 'em.
You da man!
You the man, ted man!
She's still alive, I guess.
Oh, "We bravely stormed in, but no one was there. We took a soup can."
Uh-oh, we lost a soup can.
"Ted has always had a heart of gold. That's why we weren't really shocked to find him feeding OUR supplies to some disgusting, fat cockroach.
Both Ted and the bug seemed really happy, so we didn't manage to stay mad for long.
Although when Ted started sharing jokes and life stories with the cockroach, we became a bit suspicious.
Oh dead corpse of Delores!
I think your husband is cheating on you with a cockroach!
[laughs]
"Another radio broadcast from the military was a huge shock for us.
Not only did they postpone our rescue, they also ordered all survivors to get rid of their firearms.
Are they nuts?! How are we supposed to defend ourselves?!
It'd better be worth it."
No!
I'm not giving up my damn gun!
It didn't work for me last time,
you're not gonna make me do it now!
So screw you, and your frickin' face!
Nup, there we go.
I guess we died from sickness, finally!
God dammit!
We survived for 68 days..
How
we were supposed to survive any longer?!
I tried. I really tried.
I need to look up
guides on this, because
I am trying my frickin' best...
Was I supposed to give up my gun?
I don't know, it didn't work out last time!
It said that the government quarantined us! What a load of ass.
So this is the end of 60 seconds for now,
I'll do another episode where I'm gonna BEAT it,
ON NORMAL,
cause I'm gonna..I'm good. I'm good at this.
I'ma show you guys who's good.
(very softly) This guy!
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you..
in the next video!
Buh-bye!